look daniel craig is getting the
ultimate send-off here i feel like you
guys are having him go out with a bang
you got this dazzling
red carpet premiere what was it like
meeting the duke and duchess of
cambridge the extended royal family what
an event rami it was it was it was
extraordinary i mean that's um the venue
where they do the baftas so for me the
last time i was there i
received that incredible award and and
so to go back there and celebrate
something else these are
once-in-a-lifetime experiences you know
i'm i'm beyond grateful um that scene
with all the fans out there all the
supporters of the film and bond is just
it's breathtaking
and then to have you know the royal
family join you you just can't you you
can't ever expect these moments i was
sitting right behind them during the
entire film so i got to gauge their
reaction from their body language you're
thinking you're you got two thumbs up
uh uh that was the feeling that was a
response i'm definitely not gonna put
words in their mouths but
yeah they see they seem pretty taken
aback by the phone i mean were you like
stumbling were you what do you say to
the duke and duchess
uh i don't know for me i just try to
treat them like i would anybody else
yeah i'm sure like a dose of
uh normality is probably something uh
that's quite refreshing to
them yeah
i remember at the baftas we were
we were i met them and i just they have
a lot of questions to ask you but it's
nice to just say how are you doing how
are you dealing with all this i know
you've just had
kids uh i mean one kid specifically so
um you're just trying to be normal yeah
cause they live a very very unusual life
i imagine to make the world a better
place
i just want to be a little
tidier
rami yes man you are doing great you are
not taking your foot off the gas right
now i am loving it
thank you rachel yeah i mean what uh
it's been an incredible time for me in
in these last five years i mean i i just
blessed and so grateful to be part of uh
an indelible franchise like bond i mean
you're part of this legendary franchise
you're also in a film that is fitting
daniel craig farewell to this iconic
role but how special is this role to you
this role i mean it's very special to me
because i'm such a bond fan and i'm a
huge fan of daniels i think the guy is
such a versatile actor and so to be able
to be a part of allowing even more
people to recognize that and celebrate
it is such a gift wanted this to be a
really special send-off for him and i
think we accomplished that well it is
and
you know how to play a villain mister
you do it justice
thank you i love a transformation and
um you know you can look at all the
previous villains and what they've done
and it's it's just such a privilege to
be in a long line of really exceptional
actors and to be able to
you know hopefully do something i felt
was was very nuanced and uh unnerving
and unsettling but
something that that excited me
throughout always i just wanted to be i
wanted to excite myself with the role
and
and you know give give daniel some
surprises in the meantime you have just
hit a whole new level in your career and
you got a lot to still look forward to i
do believe october 16th is a big day for
you mister because you're going to be
hosting snl
yes
that is so cool so how are you preparing
for that stint um how are you feeling
about it i'm thrilled i'm thrilled i
can't say of course there are some
nerves coursing through through my
bloodstream but i mean
yes right yeah it's great it'll be you
know a couple
a couple weeks after the film comes out
so
who knows what we're going to do i don't
i i'm i'm sure there'll be some some
sketches with with a villain or two in
them
look you can't another great tradition
of uh something that we all love
uh to be a part of and
um you know there's another
once-in-a-lifetime experience yeah so
i'm very much looking forward to it i
can't wait to get in the room with all
those writers and talented actors and of
course lauren and and celebrate this
film and celebrate that show again
another place we can have an audience
together
exactly oh that is going to be fun i
know without it i mean we've seen you on
snl before because they've done some
some spoofs of you you've been in some
scene oh
well hello there
you can see mr robot so is there a mrs
robot
no he's a ghost he's dead they're
sketches are you going to bring anything
to the table any ideas with you
i i have a few things but of course look
this their job is to do this and they do
it so well yeah so you know be there and
and listen uh
and and yeah let them be the best
comedians and writers that they can be
and just uh
you know maybe be a nice addition to
them